servile et bibi nacéri bonsoir donc
c'est ton frère alors c'est ouais c'est
mon grand frère on a beaucoup entendu
parler de vous mais voilà c'est la
première fois qu'on vous voit on est
ravi et bibi mossi alors vous êtes là
parce que sorti le 23 octobre d'un film
très attendu qui s'appelle la mentale
scénario du réalisateur manuel
boursinhac avec vous bibi naceri à
l'affiché à vous ça me à samuel le bihan
il ya clotilde courau il ya marie
guilard il ya michel duchaussoy voilà
alors j'explique le titre la mental
c'est un code d'honneur en fait la
mental que les voyous s'impose entre
c'est ça
mais je veux dire il peut s'adapter à
tout le monde il peut s'adapter à
thierry ardisson il peut s'adapter à
nous la latte et les avantages ouais je
veux dire après ça va un peu plus haut
chez les voyous c'est bien se tenir à la
police prendre 15 ans de prison est pas
envoyer ses collègues en prison c'est
les dix commandements un peu de l'emile
commandement des voyous
tu ne feras pas tu ne feras pas tu ne
feras la montagne faut savoir se taire
protéger sa famille ne jamais trahir
c'est une espèce de de code d'honneur
ancestrale des truands sas et remonte à
très loin mais la cour des miracles il
avait déjà
ccc code d'honneur qui sont plus ou
moins respecté mais est ce assez
transmis de génération en génération à
la fois à la fois ils avaient bien il
sait bien obligé de les respecter
puisqu'elle a la sanction a été
tellement sévère qu alors vous tous les
deux quand vous étiez mômes à
fontenay-sous-bois montreuil plutôt que
de dîner du shit ou boire des bières
vous fréquentiez des mecs de mecs de 40
ans qui avait des ce genre de règles
morales déjà pour commencer et puis qu
avec des belles caisses des beaux
costards vous étiez quand même assez
intéressé par ce milieu là déjà aïe on
était envieux nous on était jeunes et on
les voyait avec leur bm avec des belles
filles dans les voitures mettre des
bouteilles dans les boîtes à billets
bien habillés et on les enviais on les
voyait mais on savait qu'ils qu'ils
avaient choisi et que d'un côté il y
avait la police et d'un côté il y avait
eu il avait choisi d'être marginaux et
il savait qu'au bout du compte c'était
soit de finir dans un caniveau et au
mieux finir en prison donc il avait
choisi il se cachait pas ils
revendiquaient c'était des voyous ne se
cachait pas derrière un costume et une
cravate mais surtout nous ressemble et
nous on était des mondes qui avait qui
étaient pas très bon à l'école en effet
ces banques et aux fonds de temps en
temps il y avait un psychologue et
oriente à terre qui venait dire qu'on
n'était pas très tellement intelligent
et qu'on dirait pas très loin dans la
vie et puis cela on avait 10 à 2 puis il
avait fait un parcours peut-être dans la
marge mais un parcours qui nous
paraissaient tu ne réussit pas mal alors
le pitch du film ça peut se résumer en
une phrase si on n'échappe pas à son
destin d'une certaine façon sa meilleure
façon de le résumer alors c'est
l'histoire de samuel le bihan qui sort
de taule après quatre ans qui veut se
ranger des voitures
il veut vivre tranquillement avec avec
une fille sérieuse et puis je dis bon là
mentale justement et puis trop respecté
par les par les voyous quoi donc il veut
il veut décrocher il veut décrocher du
truc mais au nom de la mental justement
ça me voue son cousin vous lui demander
de revenir dans la bande oui parce que
c'est mon double c il a fait quatre ans
de prison on était jeune aujourd'hui on
tient le pavé parisien on a tous pendant
les quatre ans qu'il était en prison
nous on a continué à construire on
l'assistait 1 et moi sans lui je suis
perdue c'est mon double et je le vois
travailler comme un
comme un fou et nous on a on a monté un
empire et on est respecté par tout le
monde on gagne de l'argent assez
facilement on a des clés de toutes les
portes toutes les portes s'ouvrent tout
le monde nous respecte et j'ai envie
qu'ils viennent avec nous qu'ils gagnent
de l'argent facilement il ya une scène
qui a été coupée dans le film où je lui
demande juste de prendre une paire de
jumelles de se mettre sur une montagne
de surveiller il va toucher 500 bâton et
il refuse il refuse il refuse jusqu au
jour
où il va craquer comme beaucoup de mecs
qui sortent de prison et qu'on rien et
qu'on revient dans les mains qu'on pas
de travail parce qu'ils ont un casier
judiciaire et quand les les chefs
d'entreprise c'est à pau fichier qui
voyait qu'ils ont fait 15 ans de prison
on les engage pas alors qu'il a fait des
connaissances en prison et ben il
retrouve hiva rue lauriston il va à
belleville ivaha place clichy et y
retrouve ses anciens potes et y replonge
un bien une phrase aussi qui résume
assez bien la situation s'est tu peux
pas tourner le dos à des mecs avec qui
tu as grandi c'est difficile pour lui
parce que par rapport à vous de ne pas
accepter c'est lamentable justement non
mais à la fois c'est un non sens parce
que lui là il a vécu il a vécu dans un
monde où l'argent été facile c'était des
seniors où il était respecté où il est
où il était quelqu'un d'un seul coup se
retrouve avec les mains sales à
ramasser des pommes de terre je veux
dire le fossé est tellement énorme que
peut-être que s'il avait eu des
capacités autres et pikine eu un bon job
il arrêté dans le cinéma où je ne sais
pas peut-être toujours est-il qu'il va
replonger
alors bis bis vous avez fait le scénar
effectivement vous jouez un rôle le
rouquin dans le film là et puis alors il
ya votre femme qui joue aussi là tout le
monde y ait un il ya là la mère du fils
de samy à vos enfants passé j'ai quand
même ma belle mère
elle est bien là belle-mère bah ouais
mais eu la coupe parce qu'elle danse le
flamenco sur une table et puis bon ça
faisait
alors on peut dire une chose en tout cas
c'est que c'est un vrai film de voiliers
où il n'y a pas un flic dans le film on
sait mais on n'a pas voulu traiter la
police dans le film bibi est en train
d'écrire a fini d'écrire un autre
scénario qui s'appelle deux frères ou là
je vais jouer aux policiers de la brb et
je serais contre les voyous donc ça
c'est un scénario qui est dans un tiroir
et qui est en montage là on a voulu
traiter les voyous de ce qu'on avait vu
de ce qu'on avait vécu et comment on
avait grandi avec ces caïds qu'on
admirait et qui avaient choisi leur vie
1 ils ont choisi les mecs qui savent où
ils vont et ce qu'ils font ils s'en
cache pas et le prochain film donc je
serai un policier sans rôle de
composition cette fois
dites moi tous les deux vous aurait
quand même pu finir comme ça d'une
certaine façon ça me on sait on l'a dit
si tu as fait de la taule à 22 ans 3 ans
et demi faisait chauffeur de hold up
ce qui est con mais bon ouais j'étais
fait serrer bibi pareil il paraît que
vous avez eu votre vocation pour
l'écriture à la prison de la santé c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'on dit mais bon c'est
là
bas fallait le faire soit dans la vie
soit au cinéma vous édifier
ce qui se passe faut répondre à la
question des entièrement ce qui se passe
c'est que nous la chance qu'on a eu
c'est qu'à un moment donné dans nos
conneries on a rencontré on a fait des
rencontres on a rencontré des gens qui
nous ont fait découvrir la littérature
qui nous ont fait découvrir le théâtre
nous en fait que découvrir les vivres et
ce qui a fait que bien sûr qu'on aurait
pu très mal tourner parce qu'on avait
des envies des aspects on avait envie de
devenir quelqu'un on avait envie de
david et de 2 comme tout le monde comme
tout le monde bien sûr mais sauf que
c'était le mauvais parcours et cette
énergie qu'on a qu'on a commencé à
mettre au départ dans des conneries on
l'a mis dans la littérature dans le
théâtre et dans beaucoup de choses comme
ça et on est là aujourd'hui la montagne
en est là aujourd'hui tous les trois
fait pas beau ça alors le problème en
plus c'est qu'un film ça peut se
terminer alors que ça les histoires de
deux voyous on s'en sort pas une espèce
de voie sans issue cirque on se retrouve
effectivement soit en prison soit dans
le caniveau ya pas de là deux solutions
y'a que mémé guérini qui est mort de sa
belle mort d'un cancer dans son lit
sinon la plupart des ddd parent sont
morts soit d'une balle dans la tête soit
assassiné soit alors tu es toujours sur
le qui vive à regarder s'il n'y a pas
une moto qui de suite et toujours tu
fais de propos le tour de chez toi pour
savoir s'il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui de
suisse et une vie de fou c'est une vie
de mêlée mais qu'on choisit à huy alors
si votre mère qui vous a permis de
rester dans le droit chemin tous les
deux moments a été très
était très présente sur sur notre
éducation mon père par thébaux c'est de
bonne heure le matin s'occupait pas
beaucoup des devoirs parce que il
écrivait pas bien le français mais il
savait très bien compter les pascal il
savait les reconnaître et mais ouais
moment nous à nous a élevés
et s'est occupé de notre éducation
malheureusement elle a eu beaucoup de
mal et on l'a fait beaucoup pleuré
l'a vu le film elle n'a pas vu le film
et elle va le voir le à l'avant-première
là le 22 avril va préférer voir taxi je
crois
prochain taxi je signale d'ailleurs avec
sylvester stallone quand même là ça
devient ça devient très très fort alors
au début du film sami vous jurer les
racines la religion tout ça j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] je suis de l'endroit où se
trouve ma gamelle
cette absence de racines de repères qui
à l'époque
pousser les jeunes vers le banditisme
vers la mentale vers la voyoucratie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui elle les pousse
pas vers l'intégrisme islamiste pourquoi
ils vont vers l'islamisme parce qu'ils
n'ont plus de repères parce qu'ils n'ont
plus rien et les mecs qui viennent il
est endormi leur dire voilà nous on va
te donner de l'argent qui va gagner de
l'argent tu vas donner de l'argent à ta
famille vient dieu prie dieu et voilà et
c'est comme les sectes comme l'autre
qu'on a brûlé son truc parce que ils
sont tous brunet ensemble aux états unis
sont tous cramer ensemble il les a rendu
fou eh ben c'est un peu c'est un peu
comme ça les mecs ils ont plus de
repères ils ont rien ils n'ont pas de
matériel ils ont rien du tout alors ils
se disent on va vers dieu on va vers
dieu est dieu et après il y en a qui
restent à dieu modérément et y en a qui
vont vers dieu vers l'intégrisme comme
l'intégrisme dans les autres religions
la fois on est là toute la journée nous
en bas de l'immeuble aci avec l'ami face
à dire en bas de l'immeuble avec les
potes on est là on sait pas trop quoi
faire c'est que qu'est ce qu'on fait on
va au bâtiment 23 ans arrive au bâtiment
23 ans une demi-heure en bâtiment 23
qu'est ce qu'on fait on retourne au
bâtiment 24 on sait pas quoi faire on
s'emmerde alors on nous prend prétend
sur certains médias qu on nous distribue
des choses pour pour ça avant moi je les
ai jamais vus ces choses là et à un
moment donné il ya un type qui vient qui
nous dit venait à la mosquée je parle
mais c'est l'exception c'est pas aussi
généralisée que ce qu'on veut bien le
dire c'est l'exception et pourquoi
j'irais pas la mosquée je vais à la
mosquée puis après je retrouve quelque
chose là dedans
je trouve aussi peut-être quelque chose
sans être intégriste au sens ferro rist
du terme mais on est bien d'accord mais
vous qui est quand même très proche de
cette banlieue est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une parano ambiante
là dessus ou est ce qu'il ya un réel
danger de jeunes qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux à être passés par ces
seigneurs personnellement moi je pense
qu'il ya un plus un plus grand danger
dans la came que dans la religion ouais
mais maintenant la camsa devient moins
intéressant d'un point de vue politique
ou de politique internationale et la
religion maintenant c'est mon opinion
personnelle alors comment ça va ça me
super bien parce que ça me voilà il a
des périodes voilà c'est la période
bleue il dit j'ai 41 ans j'ai rencontré
une femme merveilleuse
j'ai repris le foot
je ne bois plus ça c'est sami dans la
période n'était pas une poivrade mais je
viens c'est vrai je veux dire que que je
sors maintenant et que j'ai des copains
qui sont autour de moi je suis parti à
marrakech et je me suis retrouvé avec
des mecs qui lui collait à tout va mais
j'ai ça fait j'ai pas bu un verre de
champagne j'ai pas vu un pas bu un verre
de whisky parce que j'ai et j'ai décidé
j'ai décidé aujourd'hui de ne plus boire
un verre d'alcool et de me remettre au
sport et des données fondant montée des
intégristes voilà pour musulmans voire
d'alcool ça c'est clair la haie et alors
mais les gonzesses jatta le droit ouais
mais souvent tu es comme ça dans cet
état là depuis quinze jours après on
ouvre le journal et voilà c'est reparti
samy naceri est conduite en état
d'ivresse agression dope hôpital de la
main sur la question cette fois c'est
bon ça fait ça fait un mois tant mieux
pain bon ça fait un mois un mois qu'on
en est là et que j'ai repris le ballon
et que et que et que voilà j'ai
raccroché les gants et que j'ai même
plus envie de quand je suis avec des
copains et qui boivent du whisky et qui
s'éclate et qui doit juger j'ai trouvé
mon bonheur j'arrive à danser j'arrive à
m'amuser j'arrive à m'éclater sans boire
un verre de whisky je rentre à la maison
je suis heureux je me lève le matin j'ai
pas le casque et
et tout va bien et même pas à rennes je
vois des renard mois et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus